given how much this still resonates from
the crash of 2008 what was the genesis
what was the seed that was the
germination for this film Jim Calvin
alain de Fiori sent us a script I was in
put the Michael clothes yeah I was sorry
I was in the middle of post of up in the
air at the time so it was right after
dealing with a similar topic in a movie
where you know we have a guy firing
people for a living and so it was very
relevant in our minds and and so Jim and
Alan sin is the script and there was
something about seeing a guy being held
hostage live on TV as an entree into
what really was a very difficult
conversation especially at that time and
and yet when they when they gave us the
initial script it was much more of a
satire and we felt like well what we
need to do was develop this thing into
something that both has the satirical
qualities but but can take it a little
more head-on with a drama becoming a
thriller and so that was what Lauren I
were working with them on at first and
then eventually developing it further
with jody and with Jamie Linden the next
writer that came on I think that the the
Wall Street commentaries is sort of
obvious in the movie but also really
attracted us to it was sort of the media
conversation as well and that was a big
part of what we loved about the script
today with was it difficult or did you
have to be mindful to keep this from
turning into MBA 101 I mean that that
probably was one of the biggest
conversations we had I think you know
who the characters were for the most
part was the same characters in the
initial script and the beginning of the
development process yeah we had a depth
to them and we gave him more reason but
the conversation about sort of the whole
financial world and that became that was
the biggest part of the whole rewrite
you know we stumbled across half way
through the the development process we
stumbled across a TED talk on algorithms
and it was like an 11-minute TED talk on
algorithms and engrossing 11-minute in a
rock so engrossed a exciting it was
actually the way was it honestly was one
of the most digestible versions of
watching something about something
you've never heard of before or never
stood before anyway and it was
completely digestible and so engrossing
that we immediately forwarded this link
around to everybody that was you know we
were working with a Jody and with Jamie
at the time and and we said we'll wait a
minute this is the future this is the
future this is the now and it's the
future of how all of Wall Street's
running this is what is happening now
it's not the same old sort of you know
ticket exchange it at the New York Stock
Exchange anymore it's it's all your
monies being controlled by
pre-programmed computers were originally
when we were you know scouting locations
we went down to the original stock
exchange floor and it was such a big
surprise to us I mean we've never been
down there on that floor is empty you
know I mean it's more for show and I
think we realized how current the movie
really was the conversation the movie
that the idea that really algorithms are
really running everything and that's
sort of the sub subtext of everything
because at the movies about people but
that to us was really attractive but to
your point we didn't want to make it a
lesson we didn't want to have to take
every through it so it's there it's it's
it's part of a texture of the film but
it's not what the film is actually about
it all and when did Jodie Foster come
into this this I think was her fourth
feature film yeah this is this is her
fourth film it was a two and a half
years into the prophet about three years
ago now she came in we had we had we had
been developing independently with the
riders she came aboard and it was it was
clear within the first meeting we had
with her we talked to her for 45 minutes
I mean what was really powerful about
what she had to say was that you know
she had always wanted to make a movie
that had to do with money but just as a
location and that's what really attract
us to working all together is that this
isn't a wall street movie this is a
movie about two guys at the end of the
day that are in opposite sides of the
coin and you know they're in each dire
States in their lives although they come
from different places
is and at the end they come together and
that was the movie that she wanted to
make but set at this in this location
she wanted to explore broken people
that's how she described it to us so is
that what she brought to the development
absolutely it was it was it was holding
the beacon to who these people needed to
be at the end of the day and how we
explore the depths of their characters
and sort of creating those arcs and the
characters in the journeys of you know
when we meet Lee he's got you know he's
got to be an [ __ ] he's got to be
someone that people don't like that they
don't respect but he's not clued into
that yet and over the course of this day
he's going to realize that he might be
on the wrong side of his own you know
and so that's the kind of conversations
we would have and and like I said within
within literally an hour of meeting her
we knew she was going to be the director
of this film it was it was clear as day
what is it like then working with people
like George Clooney and Julia Roberts
who have worked together before because
clearly there's a connection there was
it hard to break into that little
fraternity and did they conspire gets
too well here's a producer as well so
probably not no I I mean it was really
honestly it a dream to be around people
that that work so well together and that
enjoy and love what they do because
that's you know being around someone who
loves what they do it's it becomes
contagious and everyone that came to
this came to it for the right reasons
and they have an amazing dynamic when we
when George came on board we knew we had
a big challenge to cast the patty
character because you know he's so
dynamic and he's so big and he he has to
have this relationship throughout the
movie with someone that's stuck in a
booth and to be able to emanate and act
against him but be you know to be able
to play ball there's not a lot of people
that can do that male or female and
she's one of the rare people that can
really you know put him up to the
challenge because in a little bit of a
buddy movie a little bit of husband and
wife which you know you guys know all
about being that you are so that was an
unusual relationship in itself remember
in network news when Holly Hunter was
constantly in William hurts here brought
a little bit of that
to it as well no I mean that was in
looking why should Jodi said one of the
gifts that Jodi brought to to the
process was the earpiece she said look
you know there's got to be an earpiece
connecting these two people and and she
would always talk about it's like
they're gonna have this relationship
through through monitors and through
cameras but they should also
relationship through the earpiece and
you know when Lee is in a desperate
moment he knows because he's used to
this relationship he can look down the
barrel of that lens and be calling on
her about something and and and she can
be clearly in his ear the whole time but
look you know when when Jimin Ellen gave
us the script originally they said you
know who'd be great for Lee be George
Clooney he'd be fantastic for and we're
like yeah great it's going to take a
little bit of work but we'll get it and
and we had look I was working with him
at the time so as far as the club yes he
clearly has a certain circle and and
julie has been a part of that but but I
had been lucky enough to already been
working with him so I think that made a
difference when the moment was right to
give him the script it was hard to
convey that relationship I think the
idea that you're being intimate with
somebody while millions of people are
watching you at the same time so much
more so with the dire circumstances you
show here yeah i mean look i think we
had talked for six months about who
could be playing opposite george as as
george was coming in and as we were
setting the movie up and you know we
talked about all sorts of people and the
name that was the first name and a name
that was the last name and then was sort
of the litmus test against anybody we
would talk about was always Julia was
always this relationship they just have
they have something it's very hard to
describe I think everybody the
audience's seem to think they have a
relate like a real relationship and the
first movie they ever did together was
Ocean's eleven but people at that time
had thought they'd been in had
relationship forever and there's
something there's just an automatic
chemistry it's a Tracy Hepburn so it is
and it but it just bridges the gap for
this particular film in a way that most
movies don't even have two most most
movies you have two people that are in
scenes throughout the movie these guys
they have a scene at the beginning and
they have a scene at the end that's the
only two times they were in the room
together in the movie
the rest of the movie you know Julia was
knitting in the back during her lifetime
I mean literally we shot all of the
stage stuff at one at one time that was
one that was the first month of shooting
and then this sort of the next piece
after that was shooting all of Julius
stuff in the control room and so we had
already shot the TV footage and had
edited started editing it and then put
it up on the screens and monitors for
her to act off hmm it's a testament to
her ability to perform against you know
pre-recorded materials incredible and
then be emotional did you shoot the
street scenes where they're out you know
making their way to find the the bad guy
that was that in New York that was on
Wall Street once so would they bullish
or bearish about you and Wall Street
they were it's completely supportive
well except that's a stock exchange
student except for the new your socks
you need to do with us um we actually
would be they know about the real well
they honest they don't they don't let
anybody shoot there anymore so that's
what they told you that's what they told
us and so we accepted it very I think we
thought we got about a 12-hour approval
and then they quickly pulled pulled the
approval someone got someone got in
trouble for letting sirs for approving
us to shoot there we we embraced new
york in new york actually embraced the
film we decided we had to shoot the
movie one hundred percent new york and
that's a tricky thing to do with a movie
of the size or trying to squeeze the
budget down and it's so tempting when
you have a movie that shoots you know
half of its indoors on a stage you could
shoot that anywhere but we we were
absolute about that he had a tremendous
amount of support we actually were
completely surprised but we weren't
really trying to vilify anybody in
specific we had financial advisors
there's a whole slew of them we were
talking about right there as the special
things came out including the former
secretary of labor we had a slew of
financial advisors giving us their
opinions and help throughout the whole
process and and only very rarely did we
hear I mean everybody shared their own
sort of biases about it and there were a
lot of you realize how political it is
actually and that there isn't right and
wrongs that sometimes people are
twisting things a little bit because it
suits their politics for whatever
they're trying to sell I think that was
the biggest I opening thing as getting
an email once
you know someone really upset that we
were making this movie and you know
there they said that you don't want to
stop people from from scaring them from
investing you know and you had facts we
had you know about 20 different people
that we spoke to over the course of a
couple of years and some of them would
just contradict each other completely
and so there's a lot of gray zone and in
that gray zone is sort of where this
movie sits I guess that's where Kyle got
stuck you know and did have you heard
from people or seen responses to the
effect that this is what happened to me
yes and there were people again so some
of these financial advisors had gone
through there was a guy at night capital
a very famous company that went through
it was it was an algorithmic glitch they
had they lost four hundred million
dollars over night and never recovered
the company went out of business and and
this was a guy him and he was in our
office almost in tears at one point
talking to us about his story and trying
to help get facts right about how this
could happen even though it's completely
unbelievable and even though this
financial advisor over here said that
could never happen they people don't
even understand how it happens and
people don't even understand in the
financial world how algorithmic trading
is really working and so there's a lot
of I mean there's no other movie in that
old movie that goes into that but but my
point is is is yeah people people really
embraced it and thought it was really
important to be able to share the
stories will you please thank Daniel do
Becky and lalala madinia oh thank you
thank you very much cutie really
appreciate it